مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
الجديده للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه طبعا نستضيف اللواء
فايز الدويري المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجي لكن نبدا من تطورات المشهد
ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه مع الزميله
سلام خط سلام شكرا زين تطورات مستمره
ومتسارع في قطاع غزه شمالا ووسطا وجنوبا
سنبدا من جنوب القطاع الج الاسرائيلي الان
ارسل لواء اضافيا هناك سبعه الويه باتت
تقاتل في منطقه جنوب قطاع غزه الهدف الاول
والاهم بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي هو مدينه
خانيونس يقول انها معقل قيادات حركه حماس
اي بحسب ما لدينا من معلومات ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يتوغل بعد الى داخل المدينه
القتال لا يزال عند اطراف المدينه الاطراف
الشماليه الاطراف الشرق الشرقيه وقليلا
نحو
الجنوب الاليات
الاسرائيليه لم تتوغل داخل الم داخل
المدينه وهناك مقاومه تصف اسرائيل بانها
شرسه جدا وقتال ضاري يجري في خانيونس حتى
الان لم تدخله اسرائيل قبل قليل شاهدنا
صورا لما قالت انه تفجير انفاق سمتها
باستراتيجيه الى الشمال من مدينه خانيونس
ولكن ما الذي حدث اليوم هو ان القوات
الاسرائيليه اعلنت فجاه انها استهدفت
منطقه خزاعه منطقه خزاعه هي المنطقه
الحدوديه المباشره مع الحدود الاسرائيليه
احد الالويه من الويه النخبه توجه الى
خزاعه ويدور قتال ضار في خزاعه وهناك
عمليات استهداف لجنود واليات لماذا نقول
توجه لان الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما دخل
القطاع لم يدخله مباشره من الجانب الشرقي
هو اتى عبر شارع صلاح الدين ثم بدا بعمليه
الحصار ومحاوله اقتحام مدينه خان يونس
التي ما زالت مستمره نذكر بان من يقاتل في
خانيونس هم ان الويه نخبه نخبه مشات لواء
كثير الذي استبدل لواء جولاني هناك لواء
المضلين هناك لواء جفعاتي هناك الويه
الاحتياط ذات الخبره القتاليه العاليه
كلها موجوده في خانيونس وتقاتل بالانتقال
الى وسط مدينه غزه الامور لم تكن اهدا على
الاطلاق قبل يومين او ثلاثه اعلنت اسرائيل
انها بصدد اقتحام مخيم البريج وان سيرات
طلبت من السكان التوجه الى مخيم دير البلح
ولكن طبعا استهدفت المدنيين اثناء
نزوحهم حاولت التوغل ايضا الى مخيم البريج
لم تتمكن من ذلك القتال شديد جدا وكتائب
القسام تبرع دوما في خداع الجيش
الاسرائيلي بحقول الغام فجرت حقل الغام
كبير جدا بمدرعات للاسرائيليين واوقعت
قتلى واوقعت خسائر اليوم حاولت اسرائيل
الضغط اكثر من مره طوال اليوم لاختراق
مخيم البريج لم تتمكن من ذلك طلبت اسنادا
جويا لتامين تراجع الياتها وجنودها تحت
ضربات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه القسام وايضا سرايا
القدس ولكن كل ذلك لا يعني على الاطلاق ان
شمال
القطاع لم يعد فيه اي قتال على الاطلاق في
شمال قطاع غزه هناك قتالا مازال مستمرا
رغم اننا دخلنا تجاوزنا الشهرين في
العمليه البريه و يعني نقترب من انهاء
ثلاثه اشهر في هذه الحرب
اليوم اشتباكات كانت في حيي الدرج والتفاح
شمال مدينه غزه قتال داري كمائن استهدافات
من قبل كتائب القسام وايضا مزيد من
الخسائر في صفوف الاسرائيليين على صعيد
العتاد وايضا على صعيد المقاتلين انسحبت
القوات الاسرائيليه من الشيخ رضوان لكنها
بقيت عند تخومه حيث يجري القتال بينهم
وبين فصائل المقاومه وجبال
لم خرجت منها او انسحبت منها القوات
الاسرائيليه الشجاعيه ايضا لم يعد هناك
وجود اسرائيلي داخل حي الشجاعيه هناك نقاط
تمركز لحظيه بمعنى لا تتمركز القوات بشكل
دائم ومستمر وان تتحول الى ما يشبه
القاعده الميدانيه تتحرك الاليات لكن
متواجده عند تخوم حي الشجاعيه وهناك اليوم
مجددا القسام في في الشمال اسقطت مسيره
اسرائيليه مخصصه
للمراقبه لمراقبه القطاع وهي الثانيه في
غضون 24 ساعه زين هذه بشكل سريع ابرز
التطورات القراءه معك بالفعل سنقرا ذلك مع
اللواء فايز الدويري سلام شكرا جزيلا
اي طبعا كثير من من التطورات في الواقع لا
ندري من اين نبدا لكن ربما الحديث عن سبعه
الويه في خانيونس
والجنوب هذا عدد كبير جدا يعني سبعه الويه
دعنا نقول في شرق
ومحيط خان يونس كانت خمسه بالامس تم دفع
اللواء السادس وتم اليوم دفع لواء
المظليين لماذا لان العمليه متعثره ا لم
تصل بعد رغم كل المده شارع صلاح الدين
القوات التي ذهبت من القراره باتجاه مدينه
الحمد و الى منطقه المواصي لم
تحقق او تحافظ على ادامه زخمها لتعمل
عمليه التطويق القوات التي اندفعت قبل
فتره من منطقه الفخاري لم تحقق انجازا
الان عادوا الى الخلف للمواجهه بعض ال
الجيوب المقاومه التي لم يستطيعوا ان
يتغلبوا عليها فبالتالي كان امامهم عده
خيارات وطبقوا خيارين في في نفس الوقت
الخيار الاول دعمه باللواء السادس لم يعطي
النتيجه المطلوبه
وكانت الخسائر التي عرضت يوم امس من منطقه
خانيونس كان ومنطقه البريج كانت مؤشر على
صعوبه المعركه وعلى اخطاء ارتكبت في اداره
المعركه تمثلت يبدو فقدان عنصر المشاف ف
مباشره ارسل لواء مظليين ليعمل
كحمايه للدبابات المتحركه لانها تصبح
اهداف سهله الوصول لها وافلام اليوم عرضت
ذلك بصوره كبيره الخيار الثاني تمثل في
ارسال الفرقه 36 لمنطقه البريج ان سيرات
تعثرت في اليوم الاول عدلت خطتها الهجوم
واكتفت بدل ان تهاجم المخيمين في نفس
الوقت بدات تهاجم في مخيم البريج ومخيم
البريج بالامس شاهدنا منه فيديوهات تشير
الى مدى المعركه اذا دعني اقول الواقع
الميداني قد يكون قد يكون مازو قد يكون
مازو ما حتى هذه اللحظه لا نعرف ماذا يحدث
في الساعات القادمه لكن بناء على قراءه
المشهد الميداني لا تزال المقاومه هذا
العدد نحن نتحدث عن سبعه الويه يعني في
حدها ربما تصل الى 35000 جندي يعني الان
في مساحه ومنطقه ليست بالكبيره ما الذي
يمكن ان يفعلوه يعني انت لاحظت في
الفيديوهات اللي عرضت اذا كنت لاحظت
الفيديوهات التي عرضت في هذا اليوم اعداد
الدبابات المقدسه في الصور الجويه لاحظنا
اعداد الدبابات التي تتموضع داخل السواتر
الترابيه وتحدثنا كثيرا عن الاسباب ان
هناك تعثر في قدره القوات المقدمه على
تحقيق انجاز فيحصل تراكم فيلج الى المناطق
التوقف المؤقته دعني اقول خطه العمليات
كلها بالمجمل ليست سليمه وفاشله وهذا ما
اشار له وزير الدفاع وثري ستار جنرال
الامريكي انه لا تذهبوا بهذا الاتجاه ولا
ترتكب الحماقه الامريكيه سواء في
افغانستان او العراق عن هزيمه استراتيجيه
وهذا يعني تعبير كبير لويد ويستن حينما
تحدث عن هذه العمليه تحدث انكم تغامر
بهزيمه عسكريه لكن هل هل ما يحدث الان في
خانيونس والجنوب هو نفس السيناريو الشمال
ام مختلف لا هو مختلف نوعا ما من حيث
طبيعه الارض وطبيعه المناوره في الشمال
كانت هناك عمليه تطويق
للمدينه كانت المقاربه وتحدثنا عنها قبل
ان تبدا في السيناريوهات المحتمله وكان
التوقع بان الهجوم سياتي على طريق شارع
الرشيد من الشمال والجنوب لماذا لان
المنطقه الشرقيه لاحظ ماذا يحدث بها الان
ماذا يحدث في تلك المناطق يعني لو سمحت لو
سمحت الاخت الان في المنطقه الشرقيه لاحظ
ما ماذا جرى في التفاح ماذا جرى في اي
الشجاعيه فكانت ال كانت القراءه الاولى
لنا انه سياتي من الغرب رغم استغراب البعض
وقد جاء من الغرب وحقق واستطاع ان يدخل
ووصل الى اعماق ليس ليست بالسهل لكن
المقاومه كانت عنيفه ومعظم القتال كان في
المناطق المبنيه لكن هذا هذا الامر لم
يمنحوا الفرصه للتثبت او السيطره لا في
الجنوب المعركه مختلفه هنا يعتمد تقريبا
لا اقول يعتمد المناوره لكن حريه المناوره
لحركه قواته اكثر منها في الشمال وهل لذلك
لم يدخل الى المدينه لم لم هو يقاتل في
اطراف لم يستطع الدخول هو يعني هناك فرق
بين لم يدخل وبين لم يستع لم يستطع الدخول
طيب لدينا ايضا بما انه تحدثنا عن حي
التفاح لانه لدينا عمليات للمقاومه وصور
للقسام من حي التفاح ومن الدرج واعلنوا
قبل قليل انهم احكموا او اوقعوا جنود
الاحتلال في كمين وقتلوا عشره منهم في هذه
المنطقه نتابع في حي التفاح نتابع هذا
الفيديو من معارك غزه وفق القسام
اليوم هذا استهداف لبرج يا سيدي نعم يعني
هذا الفيديو هو ملخص لطبيعه المعركه يعني
يعطيك صوره واضحه عن شده المعارك وطبيعه
المعركه وال المقاربه التي تعتمدها هو
يوضح هذه مدرعه النمر نعم هذ هذ هذا جاءت
خبر عاجل لاحقا للفيديو اللي هو تم قنصها
وقتل على العشره لانه هي يوجد في يوجد
فيها من 10 الى 11 شخص هذه تضاف الى 22
تضاف الى 48 اليه في 72 ساعه وال
يضاف اعداد القتلى الان هذه دبابه المركبه
اصبحت المعلومات عنها حتى المشاهد بدا
يحفظ هذه المعلومات الموجوده عنها وال
اليوم كانت الاصابه واضحه جدا ل مباشره في
البرج وبالتالي كان كان امر الدبابه جسده
نصف جسده يظهر من البرج لحظه اصطياد
الدبابه وانفجارها مثل هذه التفجيرات هي
اصابات مباشره لا يمكن ان ينجو منها من
استهدف اللي
هو اللي هو العسكري في في البر لا طبيعه
طبيعه الانفجار تقول ان من في داخلها لم
ينجع لانه الانفجار كان كبيرا جدا ويؤدي
الى تفجير الذخيره الموجوده في داخل
الدبابه وقد ترقى في بعض الحالات الى بعض
الانواع 46 قذيفه وحسب نوع القذاف والبعض
قد تصل الى بدايه الستينات من القذائف لكن
في هذا الفيديو لاحظنا امر انه للمره
الاولى يكون هناك رامي رقم واحد رامي رقم
اثنين هذا لم ييك سابقا اعتقد من وجهه نظر
تحليلي صعوبه المنطقه وصعوبه اختيار مكان
ملائم يؤمن لك اي الفرصه الكامله في تحقيق
الهدف فبالتالي بسبب صعوبه زاويه النظر
على ما اعتقد اختار المخطط لتنفيذ العمليه
لانه هذا يعطيك صوره عن القدره التخطيطيه
والابداع هنا كان الرامي رقم
واحل على اريحيه المقاتل والمدافع عن هذه
المنطقه يا سيدي كان يعني هنا يعطيك فكره
عن القدره المركه انا تابعت الفيديو على
البطيء حتى اتحقق من نقطه هامه يعني رامي
اول رامي ثاني هل كلاه استهدف الاليه
فوجدت من خلال متابعه الفيديو على السرعه
البطيئه انه لا حصل انفجار واحد من الرامي
الاول الرامي الاول اصاب الهدف وبالتالي
الرامي الثاني وفر القذيفه لصيد جديد طيب
ماذا يخبرنا ذلك عن طريقه خوض هذه المعركه
من جانب كتائب القص يا سيدي هذه الحرب
اللام متناظره وهذ يعني تحدثنا ونعيد
ونؤكد هذه تميز القسام والفصائل الجهاد
وغيرها بمجموعه من العوامل خدمت خدم هذه
ظروف خدمتهم في تقديم هذه الصوره المثاليه
يعني بدءا يعني دعني اشير الى نقطه ب هذا
التكبير عذرا هذا التكبير في الفيديو وهو
تكبير بصوت جهوري يسمعه يفترض ان يسمعه
الخصم في المعرك مع صوت الانفجار اعتقد ان
صوت الانفجار التكبير جاء بعد
الانفجار لا يزال اذان مصاب بالصمم حتى
تلك اللحظه بس دعني اشير الى
نقطه كنا نقول دائما بان ما يجري سيدرس في
ارقى المعاهد هناك مفارقه عجيبه حدثت في
هذا
اليوم الجيش كوريا الجنوبيه اجرى تمرين
محاكاه للسابع من اكتوبر
وملخصه خشيه ان يتم استنساخ هذه التجربه
من قبل كوريا الشماليه فاذا ما قلناه
سيدرس بدا لا ليس يدرس بدا يطبق كتمارين
تحذيريه احترازيه واعاده صياغه عقائد
الجيوش لدينا ايضا تطور مهم اليوم تحدثنا
عنه بالامس لكن هذا التطور تكرر اليوم
ايضا وهو
اسقاط مسيره اسرائيليه م استطلاع من طراز
سكاي لارك
اثنان هذه صور
للمسيره بالامس لم يكن لدينا صور لكن
اليوم لدينا صور لهذه المسيره يعني تبدو
سليمه
تماما وهذا يعني كيف يعني هذا يطرح سؤال
كيف تم اسقاطها نعم كيف تم اسقاطها تم
اسقاطها من خلال عمليه التشويش عليها لانه
لو كانت استهدفت بنيران كان الامر واضح
الان هذه اسقطت في مكان ما تم السيطره
عليها تم تم تفكيكها للتاكد من عدم وجود
اجهزه للتتبع للتتبع ومن ثم تم اعاده
تجميعها ستنقل الى مكان امن وتوظف من خلال
الهندسه العكسيه هل يمكن توظيفها توظيفها
مؤكد اجزم لانه كل اسلحتهم من خلال
باستثناء بع اشياء محدوده جدا تعتبر تصنيع
محلي في الانفاق ولاحظنا
تصنيع قانصه الغول وغيرها
وقذائف
ياسين ت بي جي وغيرها كلها عمليه هندسه
عكسيه فهذه قد توظف يعني في في الفتره
القادمه
وستكون تطير بجانب الزواري اها طيب هذه
الطائره هل يعتقد ان اسرائيل تكون قد مسحت
من عليها كل البيانات ام يمكن ان يكون بها
بعض البيانات هنالك بيانات لا يمكن مسحها
يعني لا استطيع ان اجزم في هذا الامر قد
يكون له اصحاب التخصص لكن هذه هي الطائره
ميزتها الاساسيه اي او المثلى انها تستطيع
نقل صور حيه على مدار الساعه الى القوات
الارضيه تعطيهم صوره بابعاد ثلاثيه عن
الارض وما يجري على سطح الارض وحتى يقال
لاعماق معينه لكشف الانفاق بالاضافه الى
الطائرات رباعيه المراوح الصغيره القسام
لديهم مسيرات ايضا لديهم مسارات الزوا
ماذا ستضيف هذه المسيره
للمقاومه في غزه يعني هذه تقنيتها متطوره
اكثر ولكن هذه استطلاع هذه طائره استطلاع
ولكن الذي حول الطائرات السابقه الى
طائرات ت طئ الالعاب العاب الاطفال الى
نعم حولت وحملت
ب الياسين والار بي جي واستخدمت ضد
الاهداف الصلبه فهذه قد يعني الايام هي
التي ستكشف ما هي مدى الاستفاده
منها طيب هنالك ايضا في مقابل ذلك صور
للجيش الاسرائيلي في خزاع ربما
تكون هذه الصور نعم قال انهر فرض سيطرته
على العمليات في خزاعه احنا سلام تحدثت عن
خزاعه قبل قليل حينما
انسحب تراجعت قوات
الى ماذا لاحظت في هذه الصور حتى هذه الان
حتى الان لا توجد هذه في هذه
الصور صور للمقاتلين المقاتلين هو يعني هي
عمليه اعاده و وتكرار للافلام السابقه
وبالتالي انا قدمت اقتراح يعني في مقابل
سابقه يعني لماذا لا
يتم الاستفاده من القسام وعقد دوره لمده
سنه ليرق بمستوى الافلام التي تقدم لتصبح
مقاربه من افلام القسام او الجهاد
الاسلامي يعني هذا هو يمثل جانب واحد من
المعركه تحدثنا كثيرا في هذا المجال لانه
لا يوجد لا يوجد اي مقاتل مقابل لهم
وان كان تم تداول على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي صور لمقاتل قسامي تزعم اس انها
قتلته نعم هذا هو اعتقد لكن ليس وجهها
لوجه اعتقد انهم ندموا على على على بث
الفيديو لانه هو اولا من قبل طائره مسيره
تم استهدافه اصيب بشذ في الظهر تسامى فوق
الجراح جمع ما تبقى لديه من من قدره واراد
ان ينهي حياته ساجدا فكانت رساله بان من
لديه هذه العقيده مجنون من يفكر انه ينتصر
عليه ولم يكن في قتال مباشر وجهها لوجه لا
لا هذه من طائره مسيره طائره مسيره وليس
في معركه ولا في فيديو هذه طائره مسيره
جاء نصيبه قدره وبالتالي هو اصيب بظهره
كان يركض قبلها في في في بطريقه ما ومن ثم
تم اصابته و سقط على الارض انهى حياته
ساجدا ارتقى شهيدا اها هو سقط على الا وخذ
ساترا اولا لكن لما ايقن انها النهايه
فاثر ان تكون نهايه رفع سبابته نهايه مشه
ونطق الشهاده ثم سجد نعم نهايه
مشرفه نحتسبه عند الله شهيدا انت قلت
سيندمون لماذا سيندمون لانه كشفت ما يعني
كشفت حقيقه المقاتل المقابل مقاتل لديه
عقيده وايمان بقضيته ويدافع عن وطنه وعن
حق تاريخي لا اعتقد انه يهزم فبالتالي هم
كشفوا اوراقهم بان هذا هو هذا هو المقاتل
المقابل ايضا الالغام
استخدمتها فصائل المقاومه كثيرا و تحدثت
عن اصطياد الكثير من الاليات والافراد في
حقول الغام ما نشاهده على الشاشه الان هو
محاكاه محاكاه نعم هذه يعني اكثر من مره
حصلت يعني اخر المره هذه والمره السابقه
في جحر الديك
كان قد تم
تحضير الغام هذه الالغام تربط بطريقه
معينه لا داعي للدخول بفنيات لكن تفجر عن
بعد عندما تصبح القوات المعاديه ضمن المدى
التاثيري لهذه الالغام وتفضي الى نتائج
مؤلمه للطرف
الاخر اشكرك شكرا جزيلا اللواء فايز
الدوير الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي